ready welcome once again to the Android
emea developer relations office hours
where we talk to you about anything
that's on your mind regarding developing
android applications I'm Sparky coming
to you from a very cloudy and foggy
Munich Germany and I'm a typical fall
day here in Central Europe and I'm also
joined by oh looks like Matt Nick rich
and who's that fourth guy in London this
is the fourth guy London hi my name is
Eva and I'm from one of the organizers
of the Dutch a node user group visiting
here in London yeah it's the the run-up
to drink on UK the largest Android
focused conference in Europe I guess
each year and it's kicking off tomorrow
so droids are appearing in London from
all over Europe so very pleased to be
joined by viva here and of course is a
cohort yo Han has joined us
electronically as well unhe to our son
for joining us pretty much always good
have you on board i guess i'll see you
tomorrow in person at droidcon
absolutely yeah wouldn't miss it for the
world excellent oh yeah how come you're
missing a droid phone yo han ah good
question good question I think it's
probably maybe this is where is the
money Zig about droidcon Holland yeah
that's true as well what is that open
end of which you speak now that's one
thing of course there are many
conferences and I'm I desperately want
to go to a google i/o next year so I'm
not trying to throw my management with
it Roy Cohn UK and as you say Nick air
we have a dork on in in an event
netherlands as well so and we boost
there so it can report back to us so
basically that's it I'm on a mission
excellent well I'm definitely really
looking forward to joy premise here be a
biggest baddest Android conference ever
want to say bad in the Michael Jackson
sense yeah gettin da jia okay so onto
android um so before we kick off with
the modern
two questions I'll make the standard
disclaimer that we're not going to talk
about any road maps future products
anything that's unannounced and if
anybody from the floor inside the hangar
has a question for us live please go
ahead now else will hit the moderator
well basically I was trying to find out
what the status is on the grade all
built because way to preview and how
focus is google to get this into black
production phase or where we can
actually use it in production yeah I
think it's classified as experimental at
the moment I think that's how they refer
to it in most of their posts so I don't
know is the answer like oh you probably
focus a lot closer than I actually have
is it is the aim to kind of like trying
to get it to production quality or is it
more of an experiment to find out what
we need or AIDS it's currently on the
experimental side but the idea is to
replacing current build system with
something that Jake wardens happy with
or rather something that has four more
features and can deal with more
situations so eventually it will become
a replacement for the current build
system and there'll be an overlap time
but it's very early days yet so best
thing is to jump on to ADT dev the
google group and follow it on there and
contribute back if you think it's not
going in the right direction we sit on
them preteen or pointy I believed her
yeah okay very days okay thanks ivy um
had a head of play of it yet yeah yeah
just a simple simple build just and
tried one so I haven't tried it for a
for production yet i'm using my even by
the way so not entirely acted with the
airshow onions uh-huh this rule I see to
get my hands on Grey's look really cool
alright so let's do this in the Hangout
is we got it
tell me that's not me that going doesn't
look like okay I've got a bunch of
people in the Hangout now the live
stream just freezes in this border yeah
not English oh we've got Luda l
android-developers internist who is this
giuseppe johan we got in lindon darling
Bobby J welcome glad to have you all in
the Hangout it's really great to see
such a big group here um does anybody
else have a and a topic of interest are
concerned he would like to bring up um I
don't you guys here we good yeah yeah
all right uh so I actually had a
question just because I'm a pretty new
developer I haven't programmed or
anything like I just started his past
three months anyway long story short I
came out with my first appt yesterday um
and I'm not sure if this is the right
forum
to actually come on top search results
my appt is still not the top search
result for its own name yeah you see
that's I mean I'm trying to show you my
friends the name of the application and
they just can't find it so kind of sucks
yeah sometimes they're definitely near
the the start of an application launch
it can be best just tickling people
straight with the package name to your
application also if you search for the
package name it will appear obviously
when you're searching for app titles
then search rankings to apply so it's
going to be all down to numbers of
installs ratings and 198 other different
factors related whatever to have we
bring listings in the Play Store or
maybe in the unmanifest there is also
the possibility that your friends
devices aren't supported by your
application so it may be filtering but
often it's just the the market filtering
out some of the apps with fewer installs
so getting some installs of your app
will definitely help it appear in the
search rankings and appear further up in
the search rankings gadget and Ritva
sometimes what's your thought um it's
called have to do and it supports all
the way down to API level four so yeah
the one issue we've heard of before as
well is if you have you know the name of
your app is close to a dictionary word
but slightly change just like you know
just a one word different to a
dictionary words sometimes our query
rewrites you know did you mean it can be
a little bit too aggressive so in those
cases you can report that using the
developer console you can move a report
developer issue and we'll take a look at
that to measure our search algorithms
not being cured very rights have to do
this from yeah yours is it time yet that
it doesn't sound like a case that but
have to do is quite a generic set of
three words that could relate to many
perhaps it's I mean if you called it do
list in split separated by spaces then
put quotes around the phrase
and that'll fix it here I tried that
come up oh it's quite a generic name
though there's a lot of a lot of apps
fighting for to do we packed yeah it's
just where that you know exactly that it
you know like the guy mentioned if
quotes around it would help but
apparently not yeah package names should
usually do it you know but um you just
need to get some installs and hopefully
will start appearing the rankings
consider personally if we consider
changing the name as well because yeah
I'm gonna be that easy to search for
that name unless it becomes a really
consumer orientated brand to be more
unique be more unique on the name than
calling it something to do oh okay and
congratulations on launching your first
up yeah awesome they get anything else
from the Hangout I've got a carryover
from last week where someone was asking
about trustzone on processes and using
it for secure processing uh-huh I it
tends to only be used on boot loaders
basically what happens with trusts own
is it sets up two separate worlds on the
on the core of the multi-core device
where the two cannot communicate accepts
are a very well-defined API and it
assigns hardware resources to work from
two one or the other world android tends
to run in what's known as the normal
world and things like secure boot
loaders and stuff tend to run in secure
world so it tends not to be something
that will be usable from an application
for android and it's more designed at
hardware manufacturers to use so
hopefully that Carrie answers last week
question come oh thanks I extra detail
any of their life wishes knew who do we
have Giuseppe how are you did you have a
question for us oh we can't hear you
that mmm you may be muted yeah just
happy sperm unit I was he beeping
earlier I was at the BP noise
if you have a message for us we still
got in here you just happy so maybe just
type it in the chat window or find out
how to unmute I think there was a
Whizzer question in the sidebar as well
before we dropped out in lindon yeah is
anyone still got that or is Lyndon yep
Lyndon says is there a means to
determine if to when you mean hourly
talk yes or 2q an accessibility
announcement ok that's it so that's good
it just up and then we'll get back to
the sidebar there ok I just said sure so
you must hit me now right yes very good
so I already hello already asked this
question to reach her the in Italy
because I had the good chance to meet
him here last week right and we still
confused the rich other frankly speaking
about the action by problem because we
are still getting from this Jake wetin
information that he want to leave this
this project so we are using this
actionbarsherlock for old version before
only combo we are using this shell Akbar
action bar for our application but we
don't know what to do else because the
action bar compact that the Google team
is developing it stopped there from long
time now and not any update anymore and
actually we don't know what that's it
that's my question that moment so what's
the actual question so the question is
we don't have a compatible action bar
that does what he wants and Jane Watson
saying he's gonna stop working on his
own one what should a developer do
should his Jegs or 20 Jake said that he
posted on g+ but they're dedicated for
inception based sorry when what did Jake
actually say he's not going to say if
they that during the last day oh he was
a very good received by the Google team
but after this this time no any more
contacts know any chance to include the
probably the action bar sure look inside
the
and probably he will leave the project
and will not update anymore this is only
his block right now okay I haven't seen
a vision and I can't come get on that
but i guess the situation is the
actionbarsherlock works very well on all
the devices so I wouldn't be concerned
I'm in fact I i always recommend it to
developers Rebecca's compared to be it I
think it's fine to use if he's not going
to carry on work on it I think that's
fine too you know say any new
functionality gets added to the action
bar for for example in the future
perhaps it won't be better or tutorial
devices but you know you audio a certain
functionality level now which is good
enough Google i/o we said we are going
to release our own backward compatible
action bar version which is you know we
obviously haven't carried out yet we
haven't launched that yet but I believe
it's still coming and so there was
another project so just to say they get
confused there was another protocol
actionbarcompat which is in the SDK
samples which was that's not the same
thing that is an older much much more
simplified kind of it looks like an
action bar but doesn't offer the same
kind of an API surface for example and
that's an older project which has been
deprecated in favor this you who are in
which we have announced but not lost yet
so I hope that's clear that yeah so I
would say you shouldn't have any fear
using action Marshall right now it's a
really really awesome project and it's
open source so even if jake lose it then
you know many many many other
contributors may still and pick up the
reins and yourself included at plus
there's also this forthcoming project
from from google itself which if you
choose to wait that's your decision but
until then there's action water okay
very good question where to go dance
work thank you very much and I love him
I I instant that question in the
moderator in three words I said use what
works it's a good bike yeah okay shall
we move on to the first water rights
question talking about the moderator oh
no we said we look at lyndon's query
sorry in the sidebar yeah we've also
just had the first moderator question
because that that question was in the
moderator two birds one stone dead right
can someone read what's in the chat but
it's a distant sure is there a means to
determine if a talkback is currently
talking or to queue and accessibility
announcement goes on to say you're a
good good of an obsessive movie of that
is what I meant yeah 15 people in HPT
Chevy um I don't know I mean right
because these these these audio audio
patches tend to play asynchronously
don't think so i don't actually know if
we have an API to say no it hasn't
finished yet you guys know I don't know
either with talkback I kind of assumed
it was pretty autonomous telling what to
do it just gets on with it in its own
time queueing up things and talking
about them but I haven't used it myself
in anything so more as to put content
descriptions in my my xml tabs Thanks I
don't know the answer fan year perhaps
Eden and if you could post that question
to stack overflow and send us a link
might be the best way to tackle this
question yeah we can say that when I
flying on stack overflow he is currently
doing a post delay to interrupt and be
the last thing talking ya fer nothin no
sorry but we haven't too much experience
in that too to comment right now but
yeah the stack overflow idea would work
well for us put it on Stack Overflow
will check it out on there and see if we
can answer offline cheers and next from
the moderator spoki sure let's see what
we've got queued up questions in the
cheapest rate as well region mind this
is from writing a rainy in Austria would
you mind explaining the best way to
animate changes to the action bar such
as expanding collaborating it collapsing
an action view or replacing the
available menu items I responded by
saying I just I just call them a call
the methods and let the system do it it
will but there is a very very easy way
to get a simple animation too much as
you just put this into your style dot
XML you can put
android colon animate layout changes
true and that property will then
actually animate the insertion of a new
item into your action bar instead of
just having it pop into place so it's
not a you know it's not like a great big
animation at least it gradually slides
all the existing items over and puts it
in there I've not tried that is that
similar to when you invoke the context
traction bar any kind of dessert nice
little rotate to animation some reason
it's not a rotate it's just a little
slide into place sounds cool cool no
yeah we ready where do you put animate
changes where do you state that um I so
it's just listing it's uh it's listed as
a property on so this is it's listed as
a property on view containers but I
didn't see any way to access the action
bar as of you container I didn't find
any any API to hang that on so I put it
into the top level of of style dot XML
so its own every day of change we
animated yes exactly that's what I did
so mmm sounds a little bit too broad it
should probably be able to purchase the
action bars it now yeah I couldn't I
couldn't find an API to specifically
hang it on the action bar maybe there is
one but I didn't see it so okay I'm
going on to say there are also some
there are some callbacks that happen in
response to adding things to the action
bar and you could always catch those
callbacks and insert your own animation
if you wanted to you know draw you know
draw animator rectangle it's Sybil's
going from your from your button to the
action bar and then pushing push
everything over and grow it into place
something like that because probably you
could probably patch into those
callbacks and put that in yourself with
you in action d perhaps
because expanding plus in action view so
essentially you're right to your own
view aren't you actually viewed like the
search viewers so I think once you're in
that territory you can just use the
normal view property animator methods
okay I see that Giuseppe has given us a
question on the sidebar he says I would
like to know if the future if for the
future google is planning to do any own
ide specific for android instead of
eclipse you know I've been in companies
that have gone down that road before and
making your own IDE is a huge amount of
work with relatively little marginal
additional benefit and that's why there
exists things like eclipse which company
is very commonly will either fork which
is also an approach I don't recommend or
write plugins for as we do today we just
get the height join the Eclipse
Foundation yesterday or something like
Google became a strategic member of the
Eclipse Foundation which means it's
going to provide the organization with
eight full-time developers to work on a
clip so hopefully work from the inside
rather than making a copy and working
from the outside good boy stability yeah
that's much better and I think generally
our approach with the Android tolling as
well is to try to be as IE agnostic as
possible it's a while we try to provide
good support in a clich because that's
you know and the most use ID my java
developers out there i think most of the
toiling is designed to have an API
surface that can be hooked into
everything so tell you Jake for example
is very popular an idea that is able to
take advantage of all but many ADT
improvements quite quickly so yeah I
think we attack it from boyfriend's
ready yeah so I'm actually really glad
to think that we're not making our own
ID I think that would be a mistake
excellent excellent our son is typing is
put a link to just the URL figo eclipse
thanks thanks all okay uh you said that
we have some questions in the common
thread hmm a multitude multitude of
questions in the common thread my
goodness firstly david says nice shirts
Thank Cheers I'm classic I'm he's gizzle
oh yes strong shirt and then also goes
on to us a flatus first to get our
attention and then asks and do you think
to include QR technologies more in
Android systems to which I would
probably say yeah don't know the
original zxing zebra crossing language
did come out of Google right ah so
everybody has the capability to have QR
technologies inside every single Android
device and every Android app so I'm the
only thing we could go further would be
pre installing that on the app's I guess
on the devices but that doesn't sound
like something we go and do I like it
when the OS doesn't try and do
everything as well they kind of leaves
room for this vibrant and up kind of
muddle my ecosystem out there but by
standardizing on certain intense you
know they can all compete they may be
nice if the camera recognized QR codes
and said you don't have a QR code
scanner stores would you like chisel it
can make goggles the default camera app
but goggles doesn't even come
pre-installed does it know the one of
the things would be putting it into the
framework would cause a problem for
Google TV which course doesn't have a
camera embedded in it so what
applications day yeah true just like the
camera rapids in the frame one um yeah
uh but really I think against that is
every comment i think having a QR reader
is really nice QR as a method of sharing
leaves a little something to be desired
so for for the pressuring you x I think
we're leaning more towards NFC instead
yeah high five that beam this goes 50
people go into high fivin ficm anyway
yeah high five slow slow motion hi
on the way through you want to read this
one of the long questions to help a 10
inch tablet is such a question so Andre
question 1 of 3 we're working on a
product that uses in-app subscriptions
when the app / service is running it
uses some of our server resources that
cost us money and the problem is what
can we do if someone creates an account
via subscription and then shares the
account between 20 people or worse on
some form can we only allow save five
simultaneous connections from one
account to be active at the same time I
know that if you buy some in your
account it should be accessible on all
of your devices I hope the suggested
solution doesn't break this rule
services accessible but you have to
disable it first or somewhere else well
it sounds like you're allowing people to
buy a subscription to a set of logon
details that aren't related to their
device which maybe isn't a great idea I
mean if if you buy a subscription then
you should tie it to the account that
the subscription was purchased from
because then you can check if the person
has a subscription and if they're logged
in with that email address all their
devices they get access to that
subscription from all their devices be
saying if they share that account yeah
because you get the treat MyChelle
account just for buying the subscription
that would break the entire clay model I
mean you can buy every app in one
account to share it with a thousand
friends she would push shut it down but
it seems I calculus to that some of the
Google Play properties do ref counting
that the the other day I was a little
bit surprised that was not expecting it
I tried to listen to a music track using
google music and I got a lot of boxes at
attention you have you already have 10
devices registered to this google music
account please deauthorize one yeah
anyone who tests a lot of devices gets
that I've been there as well it's not
just cuz we all have 10 devices each but
as us this is a problem i faced with
euro sport as well if you subscribe to
that and it only allows five devices so
as you migrate across devices and you
change handsets and tablets the service
provider needs to provide an interface
which we do for google music and
Eurosport do as well where you can log
into the internet and then say no longer
works on this too
this device with this device so that's
why the end the question is asking can
they do that can they you know have a
maximum number of devices which you
allow the subscription I don't know and
does it break any rules to do that I
don't know of any rules the breaker
yours what does it and we've never I've
never heard any complaints it's only
about it that's easing I subscription
music it does seem like you are to be
able to say you know I suppose to see
the terminal more than five devices in
one day perhaps or something like that
it's going to come down to whether you
start getting bad user feedback and
lower ratings in which case you need to
change your system really i mean the
users will revolt if you implement it
poorly so that they're constantly having
to authorizing the authorized devices i
think is happily i think is mostly
concerned is in convening is he breaking
any of our rules because we're very keen
on subscriptions been develop on all the
users devices I'm you answered I don't
think any of us know by doubt it yeah I
yeah let you say if you start getting to
feedback then your SS like you do
something wrong I don't think anyone
would sit there complain oh I've tried
to down this download this onto my 20th
device and you're saying I can't do it
what's what's wrong hey yeah it's
actually I mean seems like an
opportunity for an ask for the Google
Play infrastructure to you know watch
for signs of abusive numbers of devices
configured to a single account or
something like that yeah i'm sure it
already does so cool things flags to fly
so should i move on to question 2 i'm oh
no this over three go on that number
tape and why doesn't the billing service
give us the account that was used for
the in-app purchase it'd be really
useful when there is more than one
account on the phone now anyone on a
rigid phone can just copy the DB say
that you bought the description we can't
verify if they count the port it is
really on the phone because we don't
know which one it was when you encrypt
the DB with some device unique key it's
just a minor bump on the way to create a
crack up so yeah getting access to the
actual account it's an interesting month
doesn't the google play merchant
transaction history say what account it
does but it's awkward to get to and it's
not on the device hmm um you get the
transaction ID on the device right hmm
you could use it to log into App Engine
application using the account manager
which would register that subscription
as being active and that would give you
the details that come from the account
manager for the google account yeah
there is a bit of a disjoint isn't
asking users to choose which you can or
how do you know which account it if they
have multiple council until I sell and
there'll be the problem they'd have to
select one but I'm guessing if they're
buying it they they'd pick which one
they want to associate with if you pop
the dialog up saying which of the Google
accounts on the device do you want to
associate this subscription with bri the
best that I would think that you
probably couldn't associate the
subscription with any account other than
I'm on the body the body out but can't
you get a list of purchased items from
the billing service for the login
account this is no sample advocate doing
or going into a misfortune cyberstalking
actions and then you totally could find
out which is the see a current account
logged in is the one that bought the
thing you can find out you'd have to
match transactions idea otherwise you
can you just answer then say no you also
restore transactions works on the
account deported from not the one that's
currently logged in yeah there is a bit
of a disjoint I guess it'd be nice to
have an apo you say this is transaction
ID this is the account helped in so much
of the billing service returned the
account yes the police otra Tony account
it might be easier if you think yeah
it's good feedback on from auditory
there on all we can do is pass that back
to the billing team yeah then see if
they come back with a better solution
hmm God must go on to part three given
the weekend thanks muffin and I haven't
found out anywhere in the docks of what
happens in the account was used for
buying this description is removed from
the phone you receive a cancelled
purchase broadcast sent by the being
serviced I wouldn't have thought no I
don't think so i don't get it still be
part of the that person are still
subscribed to it and they can still log
in to the Play Store and see their
subscriptions on the web I don't think
you get a cancellation signal honor they
going to the Play Store and heck I don't
think it's canceled yeah if they're just
only if you that would suggest that if
you reset your device it would cancel
all your subscriptions until you then
readded the the account and the dream
again yeah but i guess this kind of
comes down to what we talked about the
first question where if you start sort
of managing the user devices that
they've logged in on then this kind of
starts coming out for free there rather
than canceling it the minute they
disconnect that account from a device
they canceled it on whatever mechanism
you come up with also you don't get
cancellation notifications at the time
you just get the at the end of the
billing cycle you get that they its then
cancelled instead of
you
they did um sorry those are a common
thread that you liked um yep synced it's
ciao heiio ciao I live in phnom penh
cambodia I want to join your hangouts
now i love android so much how can i
join us I'll I just hang that circle
hanging you can come in we've got one
two three four five six so that you ever
got room I'll see if I can while I was
uh followers out of the loop for a
moment did you guys get to Giuseppe's
question about reply to comments nope
good for its buggy can I ask can I ask
in person please okay well I have a
couple of question about the play
console locate the first I think I think
that the first is a it's a very famous
but we need the utter whole find a way
to reply the people that give their
stupid sorry they comment to the
application using the review so we have
to find the solution as soon as possible
because we need to reply them otherwise
you make a lot of job loved her job and
because the user don't know how to use
the application or probably he don't
know well the English then at the whole
he would put just that one star center
your application ready to go down the
second question I i will give all the
trick I snow together then you can reply
all the second question ism we develop
an application that make possible to the
user to make a whole music job they can
Richard probably know better this
application that time talking about they
can compose music they can mix they can
blah blah blah etcetera etcetera we
would like to use the in app store to
make possible for the user to resell to
us their jobs I mean for example I make
a good music mix and make very good
music a song then I publisher on the
of course on the server maintain it by
us but I would like the in-app to resell
this product and the last question is
how do we do for the API without matches
mersin key I know that medicine key
exists only for USA and the UK people
but here in Italy we cannot use the API
because we we don't have the mentality
we have just the comet sake comics and
key that's all okay so i can talk about
the second one what was the first one I
kind of missed it I was Kenny had
replaced a client alright fair enough he
spoke about reply to comment on our
hangout that we did with the publisher
site team back on monday the Google Play
Developer console preview team and she
didn't announce anything new about it
just said that we're currently still
trialing it and we'll announce something
when we have something to announce to
announce unfortunately on the ee they
hear you want him the second questions
reasonable one to discuss so they have
an application where the users of the
app here yeah application creates answer
music and then in the app they want to
have a store well other people can buy
the sounds and music that you've created
yeah one that stores to be prepared by
our in-app purchases ok and then so
they'll get the money in the mail
distributed back across to the people
who have created the music yeah so the
only way I thought of doing that must
have unmanaged purchases at various
prices because you can't really go and
start changing your in-app purchases for
every single track that somebody lists
yeah then it's quite hard to figure out
what everybody's thought you'd have to
manage that on your game towards the you
can't disappear store and I store but
it's using our looking at bedding items
ok it's not maybe you can use a hair
internal currency I become a tie doing
it and then you can clear it in and out
you can buy credits for songs and then
plus you start then behalf manager and
transaction history yeah I like that
make it like a jukebox and you buy
virtual quarters or Nichols of your old
school
yeah yeah like work a bit and then you
can either use your currency when you
upload track through the gate currency
which you can resend in the app or you
can check it out at some point via that
becomes a problem as well I guess if
you're buying how'd you get the money
back out of the system well it would it
be a problem if you've got the money
that someone's paying to the developer
through the in-app purchasing then
essentially it's a separate agreement
between the developer and then the
person who's made the mix so then that's
outside of Google so Riley I have an
idea to suggest I do that applicable we
must have an hien upper item ina item
that allowed to the user to buy any kind
of a list any item in the list in some
lists that have this valley like points
let's suppose like coins okay Levi for
example 5 euro item 5 euro of items and
each songs one cost 1 euro one cost of
sense of you know chatter chatter and
then he can spend discredit buying these
items but at the hand the money must go
to the developers and divide the with
the Google of course I as is now but we
must found some way to give a credit to
the users and then they can spend this
money on any kind of items and the the
items will not have a price but will
have an account point value if I've
coins 10 coins like games that will sue
around do it when you're not selling the
application or the email purchase but
you're shelling the coins yeah yeah can
the application the application has been
paid by real money but the internals
items so songs chatter chatter can be by
with the coins but to get coins you need
to prepay something some part yeah I had
Willis songs be pliable outside
your application oh sorry I I didn't
forget you when the user gets buys a
song and downloads it are you intending
them to be able to play outside of your
application on say other devices I know
I know at all no alcohol does the song
or the the busiest it would be useful
only for own application cool it's just
well that's one of the things that
prohibited by Play Store is downloading
songs for redistribution yes I think the
virtual currency idea is a good idea um
yeah bit what currency yes racism as we
might help like how much of that can the
Google Play infrastructure provide for
you and i'm thinking probably not very
much basically just the management and
selling of the virtual coins is is about
them I mean as far as I know that's
probably about what you can get from
google play is an unmanaged purchase r
IC you gonna have your own suicide
infrastructure to keep track of each
user's balance and so forth yeah as well
as the redistribution of money out to
the artists yep yeah we're not gonna do
anything a little thinner that is the
point that there's a dissolution of the
money I don't think we provide anything
off the shelf for that what my google
musics launching your territory you can
encourage them to do the what's that
thing where you can sign up to sell your
own song from google music incursion to
do that awesome that's when we talk
about this app for the last 10 minutes
but you haven't said what your apps
actually called Giuseppe what what's the
application called that you're talking
about so people can go and try it out if
they want oh you're on mute someone's
muted you oh yes someone any few seconds
someone is muted give me I don't know
why anyway yeah the name of the
application needs a voice bro voice pray
those worries pal yes lots of the native
audio processing apply effects to your
tracks do lots of different processing
on them in
very fast in the background me just the
rest of the world ready no and and what
about the mess and key what about key so
you're saying that this is the server to
server in-app billing you're saying them
to use that a PID yes yes yes we can we
can't because we don't have the missing
key I thought it was a stand that I wore
to login and you didn't need the
merchant key for it have you tried to go
through the flow yeah if if I check in
my in checkout account yeah and the go
in the settings I don't have the
medicine key like other people in UK or
in USA so without the medicine key i
cannot use at all the API do you have to
do something that you could sell their
can't you want the payments to go to
make a new I'll have a quick look into
that yeah yeah yeahs class we answer the
next question of the comment thread of
the moderator yeah but if you will I
we'd love you for you will access from
UK account you will see the merchant key
yeah yeah I know that only you can us
have merchants so I'll see what what
you're setting is needed you know so
just carry on through the air to go to
the next question all right sweetie
what's next on the moderator yeah I say
welcome Loretta okay um this is from
looks like just classy in Columbia so as
a custom fragment of emanation click
can't talk custom fragment animation
problem when I pop out a fragment from
the back stack the enter animation words
the exit one doesn't because never it
doesn't show the animation then doesn't
take the fragment out from the back
stack don't know i'm i'm guessing that
if the if the exit animation is not
being shown maybe it's just that the
fragment doesn't being remove
moved from from the fragment collection
like be a fragment transaction and I
think the back stack is just a separate
issue but that's that's i'm sort of i'm
sort of speculating there i don't know
is that ring any bells with you guys
can't say i can comment on this one and
no i have the only coaches i've come
across with those is when you are adding
it see when you add the fragment and
used to specify your own custom
animations it just accepts an idea
doesn't it which is the animation type
I've had people have problems when
they're specifying the old type
animations not the new type animation so
rather than the Android that view the
animation type animation the unity is
and Android the animation type animation
so I've come across issues over that way
if you supply the wrong type of
animation because it's just an in right
it's not type-safe it's just an end
pointing towards of res ID if you're
supplying the wrong kind of animation
resource then it obviously went play and
that yeah I've had issues of that but
beyond that and without having good a
coach on the bit stumped right so you
don't ok so you nothing really jumps out
at you with regards to how to get the
animation and the back stock removal
specifically when you're when you're
getting rid of the fragment no you
should just happen right like if you
just do add to back stack no and then
when you hit back whatever it should
remove it probably from the back stack
and also and play the animation but yeah
it sounds so that's not happening so
without seeing the code it's kind of
hard to debug ok so maybe a good piece
of advice for him would be put it on
Stack Overflow on send us a link yeah
absolutely we don't answer for it Reggie
yeah again using I've been through the
subscription documentation I can't find
anything in the documentation which
suggests you need a merchant ID to use
the subscriptions server interface so
you get all the IDS you need from the
API console so if if you can point me to
where you're finding the the problem I
can look into it more but it from what I
can see you don't need the merchant ID
to do the subscriptions requests and
I've done it implementation on myself
and made the request myself and I can't
remember ever using that merchant ID for
anything hmm i will talk king are we
talking about about the same a AP iiii
AP because i'm talking about checkout
API and not store I know the
subscriptions API right now API is only
available in the UK in the US yeah I'm
going to check out I need to our checks
to the checkout datos rightly say that
place told I wrong no I'm not sure that
is possible an original forget yeah no I
remember something about that the yeah
okay let's move on my what what what
what happened if an Italian developers
open and the UK account what happened in
that case uh what especially trying to
sell stuff then you could get into your
account forget about standings you might
have to verify that you really are a UK
business and you won't be able to do
that here at some point it will give us
a verification um no problem i'll give
you your registered zombie fest if you
register a company in the UK really i'm
already i have already i can use that i
can use that but the problem is to move
the application from the older older
point to the new one what will happen
then that's simpler and i change can i
change the account and leaving the name
and the comm Datuk voice prada like the
same yes yeah you can leave an
application between developer can so
it's not a problem the only
complications there are they oh you'll
obviously have a new public key could
it'll be a different developer account
so anything which is using the public
key will have to have the code updated
so it purchases oh yes yes yes all the
things that use a public key i have to
update reboot and the publisher game but
i can republish under new name right
yeah you'd normally publish update
before the move which accepts both
public keys and then move the app and
then at some point online remove the old
public
hi before to publish to the new account
I need to delete the older application
because otherwise I will duplicate to
the name no yes no it's a move it's not
a takedown and republish you to move
it's a you don't don't do that don't
take it down and publish the same thing
because you can't because the package
name will be taken there's a form on the
Google Play help docs rich to replace a
link to that transfer form in the clinic
in the Alpha daxing the products I would
find a move there's a there's a process
you can ask us to move an application
between developer out automatically I
cannot do myself but I have it to ask on
the bench don't don't don't unpublish
one account try and republish in the
other because you will not be able to
okay so do you suggest me to open before
the UK account then keep in touch with
the back office and ask them to move
from here to here and that's all yeah
okay but if they would move they will
move using the old code with all the old
public key right yeah this is why I say
before you request the move publish an
update and to the application so the
application can handle both the old and
the new public keys then ask for the
move I've just put the instructions in
the chat window the man call you the
instructions on God is like getting a
transferred across that's how you see
that you said P so this is very soul
thanks yes all I see her food thanks
let's give someone else a chance to
think any more live questions before we
go back to the comments or moderator
yeah actually happened um when I'm
trying to write a method now that will
basically tell if there's been an update
in the application so if bc if if the
version code has changed and i'm just
trying to see trying to test this method
so um when i run it in eclipse if I just
r on the application with the change to
version code do you know if that's
comparable you're going in the
marketplace and pressing update
I don't think so i think that take that
that's that's out of band i mean that's
that's key the android or does the
Google Play application that's that's
managing it for you so it says that's
does the google play app on your device
talking to market and saying oh look
this APK changed let's offer an update
well now i have i have in my application
like on create like I have hey if this
version code change to run this but I'm
trying to test that of course before I
publish it so when I go into eclipse and
I stall it I install it first time on
version code one and then I change
something and I put version co2 will
this basic through eclipse pick up that
update so it's a kind of sense does the
transfer over as an update and not just
a clean install so depends on what
you're trying to compare it to it would
have thought you can get the version
number for the app is installed that you
need to have saved the previous version
somewhere right I think what he's asking
is they would the update process happen
if you change the version number in
Eclipse and I'm thinking know that when
you when you click run it's just going
to take your modified APK with the new
version number plop it right on top of
the old one but it isn't like you owe me
and run but that said if you you know if
you have um I mean you say you have for
example databases you can you can have
version numbers associated with your
databases and your new app can say oh
look that database is out of date let me
run the update logic for the database or
or just you know say have a shared
preference with the yeah I have it I
have it saved in the shared preference
so I guess like a mile away I think it
is a DB and stole money so I mean you
can see it come out at the logs right
when you hit yeah well so shared
preferences are persistent across up the
gap or so all right let's just file
essentially gotcha absent all right cool
cool any more live questions Spartan
maybe
sorry big sponsor helmet oh yeah no mine
shall I shall I look at one from the
moderator yeah go for it you've got I'm
trying to port some animation from html5
to Android what functions in Android
like skew rotate images can help me out
that's a pretty broad question i would
say it depends on exactly what animation
you're doing I mean html5 has canvas
animation Android s canvas animation
HTML has WebGL androids got OpenGL so
basically look at your essentially your
animation package that you're working in
and use the equivalent one in android
the only thing I a WebGL spec is pretty
close to the opengl es 2.0 skies i know
i'm not an expert on this but though if
you have just heard that exactly so yeah
I think you just need to just google for
WebGL bases opengl es 2.0 t m l in
chrome on Android and see how far he
gets some of it might actually work I
think the WebGL probably wouldn't but
the canvas animation might so no and
also there's there's the little caveat
that they that the full version of
chrome on Android is going to be a much
more powerful and future for than the
webview so what you get in a browser app
might not be the same as way you get by
embedding HTML into a native android app
date so yeah open-ended question with
lots of answers we're running out of
time so let's go real quick speed answer
modes so Gabriel asks he is launching
his app and he has plans to lay to
introduce synchronization which will
require an extra lift permission so
she's gonna counts his credentials
internet and so on should he launches
and with these new permissions they
isn't using yet or should he wait and
then increase the permissions when he
updates good question i would personally
vote for waiting and increasing the
permissions even though it means that
people will have to volunteer to the
update i think it's worse much worse
having an application out there which
asks for permissions that it doesn't use
it confuses people they wonder what's
going on
background and if you explain it by
saying i will need these in the future
it's a little bit creepy and plus people
it's better they actually read the
description and stuff they're more
likely to pay attention to the list of
permissions yeah I made the description
I wear with the minimalist permissions
that you can get away with any one stage
and plus once you've built up a bit of
trust with users when it comes to
updating with additional permissions
they kind of assume there's going to be
additional features with it so yeah
that's true next speedrun okay Gregory
asks in the action bar icon pack there's
an all icons or AI how do you extract
certain icons I guess the answer is you
use it a because you're a janitor and
relatively the separate icons should be
in the AOSP repository as individual
PNG's you can also get them I mean at
least from the end developer.android.com
/ design / downloads has some downloads
that have all the icons just as separate
that's what he's talking about I mean
the separate pings in the drawable
directories right so you don't have to
actually separate yeah but he actually
wants the vectors not that not the
bitmaps he says can he has it in SVG so
I think right now unless you find
someone very kindly to all that I don't
be gonna see that yeah find an app that
can read adobe illustrator files
especially an ask for a future comment
on when IDK what's coming so we can't
comment on future release dates yeah
I've been talking around the idea of
developing game using overlays on a
google maps map view I've got a working
prototype but how does the licensing
work for such an application can I even
use match for that purpose yes how do
you do guys if you're using map view or
maps on the mobile that's using the
client quotas isn't it not the server
botas so you should be fine it's on a
per session per client basis cool is
that there's a copy Andrea's Clara
clarifying what he meant by question 3
because if you count about the
subscription is removed from the phone
you see when a subscription has bought
we store the information on our database
then on every start we call our server
to check if the subscription is still
valid now that the account is removed
that use there should no longer be able
to
access the functionality okay a bit
confused as to why they're no longer
eligible to access because they're still
paying the subscription they should
still house I think it's because the the
account that license to the content is
no longer present on the device when the
device is trying to talk to the server
Oh in case the account if I move that
the app hasn't been removed so therefore
you're still doing it um I would say
yeah if the if the user account that
paid for the subscription has been
removed from the phone then absolutely
that phone should no longer be able to
get the deer yeah but I don't know what
I don't know I take it every way because
basically you've tied that uses account
to your notion of their account on your
server if they're still logged in with
that same account with your you know
because the source of true for
subscriptions is your server right
basically your server does it talk to us
over to verify it before it renews right
if it's still logged in with the same
like your account for your service then
I think that's valid at the same time if
the device checks through the market
whether you're still subscribed it will
come back and say no if you did restore
transactions or whatever I still think
the source of truth should be your
server and your service doing a service
telecommunication so paid up if you buy
a paid app and it's using lbl then you
take the account off the device for
those access to the app so it would be
nice review did what Nick was saying but
acceptable in either way cool yeah and
we happily I'm going to anymore
moderators quick run there for Nick fo
mats or read any update on the Google TV
and DK oh yeah so we can't really
comment on that there's a massive long
thread which I think crispy or Christian
uccello as responded to so I'd literally
just follow that because I think we are
following that thread Fred where it is
on google issues somewhere I comment
with combined english is anything i get
and then send it back yeah I'll find it
for it in the comments any quickies in
the sidebar we can come up i'm new to
android dev i would like to ask
is my own database to store the data for
my app yes going to
developer.android.com fours less
training and look at how to store data
there's a thing
training basics saving data written by
our very own munich-based Sparky road I
shall write in the chat bar for you as
my last thing so you have to copy that
if we so so just going back to an
earlier question I wanted to comment
about the SVG's you're talking about
Adobe Illustrator if you want a poor
man's method of working with SVG's the
last time I did anything with that I
used the chrome web browser to preview
it and I edited the sucker in GA in just
a raw text mom listen oh my god okay
then brings us to the end of this week
sir Android developer office hours Oh Oh
Sees we a woman that you could also
petition Alex I'll walk you out those
resources say please recently this
beauty yes and hopefully we'll see some
of you who are watching tomorrow and the
day after at droidcon London very
excited about that no yeah um bye and
we're done but thanks guys x is fun
right